I KNOW WHAT YOU SAW,
BUT, UM, IT WASN'T REAL.
[laughter]
- NO, YOU GUYS
DEFINITELY AREN'T GAY.
NOBODY'S SAYING YOU'RE GAY.
- NO.
- DUDES WITH GIANT MUSCLES
ARE NEVER GAY.
- YEAH. EXACTLY.
- OKAY, I'M SORRY, BUT...
MAYBE I AM GAY.
- WHAT? NO.
[laughs]
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
MAYBE YOU ARE, BUT I'M NOT.
[laughter]
- HE'S NOT.
- NO, YOU GUYS WERE JUST DRUNK,
PLAYING GAY CHICKEN.
SOMETIMES WHEN I GET DRUNK,
I GO TO BOSTON MARKET,
I EAT CHICKEN.
WE'RE LIKE THE SAME DUDES.
- YEAH, YOU'RE DRUNK.
WEIRD THINGS HAPPEN
WHEN YOU'RE DRUNK.
LAST WEEK, I GOT DRUNK, I ATE
THE BAND OFF MY WRISTWATCH.
I THOUGHT
IT WAS BEEF JERKY.
[laughter]
- I DON'T KNOW,
I'M JUST...
I'M JUST VERY CONFUSED
ABOUT EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW.
- OKAY, LOOK, YOU WERE DRUNK.
YOU'RE SOBER NOW.
WHY DON'T WE GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS?
JUST KISS EACH OTHER REAL QUICK,
YOU KNOW,
AND THEN YOU'LL
PROBABLY HATE IT,
AND WE CAN GET TO THIS PROPOSAL,
'CAUSE I GOT SOME IDEAS.
- THERE YOU GO.
ONE TIME, LITTLE THING,
YOU'LL SEE IT WAS JUST A FLUKE,
AND WE'LL MOVE ON WITH THE DAY.
- MM-HMM.
- YEAH, OR YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
OR YOU CAN JUST NOT DO THAT.
- DRUNK NIGHT.
- TOTALLY STRAIGHT.
- BOOM. OKAY.
- THAT WAS A STRAIGHT DUDE KISS.
- LET'S GO.
LET'S GO EAT SOME EGGS
OR SOMETHING.
- YUP, NO FEELINGS THERE.
NO FEELINGS THERE, RIGHT?
- GOOD CALL, THERE.
GOOD--WHAT ARE THEY--
- YEAH, GOOD--
- WHA--WHY? WHY?
- STRAIGHT DUDES KISSIN'.
- YEAH.
- AHH...
- WHAT'S GOING ON
OVER HERE?
- WHOA--WHY?
[shouting]
MY PREDATOR BONG!
- ALL RIGHT, THAT'S IT!
BREAK IT UP! BREAK IT UP!
RIGHT NOW!
- JEEZ LOUISE!
- AND WE ARE BACK.
OKAY, SO...
- [clears throat]
- I'M JUST GONNA MOVE ON, UM,
BECAUSE I HAD A PROPOSAL
THAT I WAS GOING TO
GIVE TO YOU GUYS,
AND HERE IT IS.
- YES.
- LET'S START A NEW RIVAL SQUAD
TO THE LORD'S FORCE.
WE CAN, UH, WORK OUT HERE,
WE CAN EVEN PERFORM
IN THE FRONT YARD...
GUYS--OKAY...
- GENTLEMEN?
- WHY DON'T YOU GUYS
JUST GO THINK OF A NEW NAME,
WE'LL BE HERE
BRAINSTORMING.
WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON?
[Barry White's
Let's Get It On]
♪
- ♪ COME ON, BABY
♪ LET'S DO IT TONIGHT
- OH, UH, I'M SORRY.
DO YOU GUYS MIND IF I, UH...
- COME BACK LATER.
- AND I WILL.
- ♪ COME ON, BABY
- OH, SORRY, DUDE.
DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE IN HERE.
- NO WORRIES.
[laughs]
- YOU GUYS
ARE SHOWERING TOGETHER?
TO CONSERVE WATER.
PFFT.
YUP.
VERY CONSIDERATE.
[wheezes]
WHAT?
YOU GUYS HAVE
MONSTER [bleep].
CHICKS MUST LOVE
SUCKING THOSE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THAT'S AWESOME.